-Mon invité a la réputation
d'être une machine de guerre
lors des campagnes électorales.
A la fois stratège, négociateur
et organisateur hors pair,
autant de qualités qu'il faut
peut-être mettre en rapport
avec son cursus universitaire,
Bonjour, Manuel Bompard.
On s'engage en politique
avant tout
pour défendre des idées,
mais votre parcours est tellement
lié à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
que je me demande
si vous vous seriez
engagé en politique sans lui ?
-Euh, sans doute,
mais c'est vrai
que j'ai trouvé,
à ce moment-là,
une personnalité qui défendait
les convictions qui étaient
les miennes.
J'étais intéressé par la politique
depuis que j'étais jeune,
révolté, je pense aussi,
face à la marche du monde,
aux inégalités sociales,
mais j'avais une difficulté :
je me retrouvais
ni dans le Parti Socialiste
- je trouvais qu'il avait abandonné
une certaine perspective
de transformation de la société -
ni dans les autres partis à gauche
du PS. J'avais l'impression
qu'ils ne s'interrogeaient pas
sur la stratégie
de la conquête du pouvoir.
Dans les interventions
et la démarche politique
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon, j'ai trouvé
à la fois une perspective
de transformation de la société,
et en même temps,
une volonté de prendre le pouvoir
et de changer la vie des gens.
-Vous vous êtes engagé
dans le parti de gauche
dès sa création
par Jean-Luc Mélenchon
en 2008.
A l'époque,
vous étiez un jeune ingénieur,
docteur en mathématiques appliquées.
Il s'est occupé de votre éducation,
il vous a fait lire des livres ?
-C'est vrai.
-Quels auteurs c'était ?
-Les classiques
du matérialisme historique,
comme Marx.
Les classiques du socialisme,
Jean Jaurès...
Moi, j'avais
un cursus scientifique,
en vérité.
Je me rappelle le premier livre
dont il m'a parlé :
"Socialisme utopique,
socialisme scientifique",
de Marx et Engels.
-Vous avez plongé
dans un univers
très éloigné
de votre parcours.
-Voilà, et ça m'a accroché,
donc après, j'ai continué.
-Il s'est occupé
de votre formation
intellectuelle, il vous a aussi
hébergé quand vous voyagiez
entre Toulouse et Paris,
que vous n'aviez pas
de pied-à-terre. Ensuite,
il vous a confié la direction
de ses campagnes présidentielles
en 2017 et 2022.
En 2022, il vous a "transmis"
sa circonscription à Marseille.
Il vous a confié les rênes
du mouvement La France Insoumise.
On sent qu'il y a
une confiance
absolue et réciproque,
une compréhension entre vous.
Vous évoquez même
une relation télépathique
avec lui.
-Ce que je veux dire,
c'est que quand ça fait
plusieurs années
qu'on travaille ensemble,
on a compris
comment l'autre personne fonctionne,
comment elle réagit
aux événements.
Parfois, il n'y a pas besoin
de parler pour avoir une réaction
sur de l'actualité
ou de la stratégique
qui est la même.
-Vous vous comprenez parfaitement,
alors que vous êtes très différents.
C'est un littéraire.
Il peut avoir
des coups de sang.
Vous, vous êtes un scientifique
connu pour avoir
du sang froid.
C'est la complémentarité
qui fait que...
-Peut être.
C'est des habitudes de travail.
Ca a bien fonctionné.
On n'a pas forcément
le même caractère,
mais on travaille
bien ensemble.
-Vous avez obtenu d'excellents
résultats en tant que directeur
de ses campagnes présidentielles,
mais votre 1re campagne à vous,
vous l'avez perdue,
en 2017,
aux législatives à Toulouse.
C'est plus compliqué
d'être en première ligne ?
-C'est toujours
plus compliqué, oui,
parce que ça ne nécessite pas
forcément les mêmes savoir-faire,
les mêmes qualités
que d'être directeur de campagne.
-Aller sur le terrain,
faire campagne ?
-J'avais fait.
Avant d'être directeur de campagne,
j'étais militant.
-Ca correspond à votre nature ?
-Oui, je n'ai pas
de difficulté avec ça.
Après, honnêtement, en 2017,
aux élections législatives,
La France Insoumise,
elle a eu seulement 17 députés.
Je crois pouvoir dire aussi
que le contexte national
était compliqué,
et sur la circonscription
où j'étais candidat à Toulouse,
j'ai été qualifié au second tour,
mais je ne l'ai pas emporté.
On a corrigé ça la fois d'après.
-J'ai regardé votre thèse :
"Modèle de substitution
pour l'optimisation globale de forme
"en aérodynamique
et méthode locale sans...
"paramétrisation."
J'y ai rien compris,
sauf que vous êtes
un pur scientifique. Il n'y en a
pas beaucoup, en politique.
Est-ce que les scientifiques
ont une façon d'aborder
la politique qui leur est propre ?
-En tout cas, je pense que ça...
On a des qualités,
des réflexes,
qui, de mon point de vue,
sont utiles
dans la bataille politique.
-Quelles qualités, quels réflexes ?
-Une certaine capacité
de rigueur, une certaine capacité
à lire les événements
avec, on va dire,
un sens de la logique.
En termes de réflexion stratégique
ou de réflexion politique,
je trouve que ça peut aider.
-Au sein de LFI,
vous êtes un peu le "G.O." :
pas le "Gentil Organisateur"
au sens Club Med,
plutôt le "Grand Ordinateur".
Je dis ça parce que vous êtes
à la fois le cerveau,
et celui qui fait tourner LFI
tous les jours.
A chaque fois,
vous avez un souci permanent
d'efficacité.
Vous êtes là pour chasser
les grains de sable
qui peuvent enrayer la mécanique.
Chez vous, l'efficacité,
c'est le préalable à tout
en politique ?
-Moi, je me suis engagé en politique
avec l'objectif
que les idées qui sont les miennes
et les idées qu'on défend
arrivent au pouvoir,
prennent le pouvoir
et soient appliquées.
Dans mon parcours, en tout cas,
j'ai toujours refusé
d'être uniquement
dans une logique de protestation
et donc c'est peut-être ça
qui vous fait poser cette question.
Donc l'efficacité, oui, je...
-Et dans tous les domaines,
comme vérifier qu'il y ait
un second micro dans un meeting
au cas où le premier
tombe en panne.
-Je considère
que quand on veut
prendre le pouvoir
dans la 5e ou la 6e
puissance économique,
mieux vaut le faire sérieusement,
sinon, on n'est pas crédible.
Je pense qu'une campagne
présidentielle,
c'est une grosse machine,
et à n'importe quel moment,
dans cette grosse machine,
un grain de sable
peut faire dérailler la campagne.
Donc j'ai toujours eu,
- et je ne suis pas le seul,
il y a une forte culture
politique à LFI -
une attention pour ce qui paraît
être un détail
mais qui, en vérité,
n'en est pas.
-Au nom de l'efficacité,
vous avez réorganisé
la direction de LFI,
sans faire valider
les nominations par un vote.
Certains anciens,
qui ont été écartés,
s'en sont plaints.
Vous leur avez répondu :
"Le vote n'est pas
"l'alpha et l'oméga
de la démocratie.
"L'objectif
est d'être efficace."
Comment est-ce que vous auriez réagi
si Elisabeth Borne
avait utilisé la même phrase
pour justifier le 49.3
sur les retraites ?
-Cette phrase a été totalement
sortie de son contexte.
Je disais que dans
une organisation politique,
il faut des modalités
de délibération collective :
ça peut être un vote, mais parfois,
il peut y avoir d'autres modalités.
Par exemple, à La France Insoumise,
on expérimente.
C'est pas toujours facile.
Au lieu de se poser la question
d'un clivage entre une majorité
et une minorité,
on essaye de fonctionner
avec des processus de décision
par consensus,
des processus de décision
où, petit à petit...
-Vous allez entre les courants
de LFI comme il y en a eu au PS.
-Oui, parce que je pense
que ça ne produit pas
quelque chose de bon.
Ca produit une situation où on passe
l'essentiel de notre temps
à nous disputer en interne
des organisations politiques
plutôt qu'à se consacrer
à la transformation de la société.
Parfois, on est en désaccord
et donc il faut voter.
Bien sûr, je n'ai jamais dit
que j'étais opposé au vote,
mais il y a d'autres manières
pour ne pas se poser la question
de regarder ce qui nous divise
ou nous sépare,
mais plutôt ce qui nous rassemble.
Voilà pourquoi j'ai dit cela.
Evidemment, il n'y a
aucune analogie possible
avec le fonctionnement d'un pays
ou d'une Assemblée nationale
dans laquelle les députés
ont été élus pour voter.
Donc je souhaite
que les députés,
ils puissent voter.
-C'est le pendant
de votre souci d'efficacité.
Aussi,
une image de "Bad cop"
vous colle à la peau.
J'ai lu votre portrait
dans l'hebdomadaire Marianne.
Il vous a surnommé
"Le nettoyeur de Mélenchon".
Sur ce thème,
on retrouve beaucoup
de qualificatifs en off,
qui ne sont jamais
sympathiques pour vous :
"flingueur"...
-Je vous confirme.
-..."liquidateur", "tueur à gages".
Ca vous agace ?
-Ce n'est pas que ça m'agace.
Ca fait sans doute partie
de la vie politique
d'être affublé de qualificatifs
qui, selon moi,
ne me correspondent pas.
-Est-ce que vous avez
pour mission de faire tourner
un peu la maison ?
-Vous savez, quand vous faites
tourner une organisation politique,
vous avez toujours des décisions
dans lesquelles certains
ne se retrouvent pas. Ca arrive.
Moi, j'essaye toujours
de le faire
dans le respect
de chacune et chacun.
Donc je ne me retrouve pas
dans ces qualificatifs,
mais ça ne m'empêche pas
de dormir.
Si ça m'empêchait de dormir, hélas,
je ne dormirais pas beaucoup.
-Dans vos multiples missions,
vous avez été l'un
des principaux artisans
de la NUPES.
C'est d'ailleurs vous
qui avez annoncé
l'accord avec les Ecologistes.
On va revoir ça en images.
-00h05 : après des heures
de tractations
et sous le regard
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
dernières politesses de rigueur,
et satisfaction partagée.
*-Vas-y, commence.
*-Toi ? Moi ?
*-En quelques dizaines d'heures,
on a réussi
ce qui avait été impossible
pendant des années.
*-Je crois que c'est historique.
Nos formations politiques
n'avaient pas fait d'accord
aux législatives.
C'est la première fois.
-Cet accord entre les partis
de gauche a laissé
sceptique au début.
Jean-Luc Mélenchon en a rêvé,
et c'est vous, en quelque sorte,
qui l'avez fait.
Est-ce que c'est l'un
de vos plus grands
accomplissements politiques ?
-C'est un moment
qui était historique, c'est clair.
C'est un accord
qui restera dans l'histoire.
Ca nous a demandé
beaucoup de travail.
Ca nous a demandé d'apprendre
à nous connaître.
Ca nous a demandé
de faire compromis,
parce que...
-Et d'engager des rapports de force.
Vous assumez d'être...
-Bien sûr.
-...très dur,
à certains moments.
-Je crois
à la franchise en politique,
et pourrais faire
semblant qu'en politique,
il n'existe pas de rapport de force,
mais bien sûr que si.
Ce qui a permis cet accord, c'est
le fait que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
ait fait 22 % à la présidentielle.
Mais le rapport de force,
ça n'empêche pas le respect
pour ses partenaires.
Moi, j'ai coutume
de dire qu'une négociation entre
différentes formations politiques
est une bonne négociation
si, à la fin,
tout le monde
a l'impression d'avoir gagné,
et personne n'a eu le sentiment
de s'être senti humilié.
Je pense que ce qui a fonctionné,
c'est que chacun, à la fin,
a fait des pas, mais chacun
s'est retrouvé dans un accord
qui était productif,
qui était efficace :
je rappelle
que grâce à cet accord,
nous avons remporté
le premier tour des législatives,
nous avons fini en tête
du premier tour,
et ça nous a permis d'avoir
151 députés à l'Assemblée nationale.
Pour moi,
c'était un historique
et ça restera un moment important
de ma vie politique.
-On va passer à notre quiz,
à présent. Avec vous,
j'ai eu envie de faire
un vrai/faux
pour vérifier certaines choses
que j'ai lues et qui m'ont étonné.
Est-il vrai
que quand vous vous ennuyez
en réunion,
vous vous détendez
en résolvant des équations ?
-Non, c'est faux.
J'ai lu ça aussi.
Ca a pu m'arriver.
-Je trouvais ça...
-Je ne fais pas d'équations
sur mon temps personnel,
et d'ailleurs,
je m'ennuie rarement en réunion.
Les discussions
sont souvent productives.
-Adolescent,
vous classiez les disques
de vos rappeurs préférés
par ville d'origine ?
-C'est vrai.
C'est vrai.
-C'est bizarre,
comme classement.
-Oui, mais j'avais besoin
d'avoir des cases
où mettre mes tous disques.
C'est vrai que je faisais ça.
-Avec des rappeurs de Marseille ?
-Oui, pas mal. C'est vrai que moi,
j'ai grandi,
dans la génération IAM, etc.
Donc c'est vrai que j'avais
un tropisme marseillais
dans mes goûts musicaux.
-Enfin, j'ai lu
que vous aviez été
goûteur de mojitos
au stand du Parti de gauche
de la Fête de l'Huma.
-C'est pas totalement faux,
mais extrapolé.
Dans les premiers stands du Parti
de gauche à la fête de l'Huma,
effectivement, il y avait
une buvette avec du mojito
pour les gens qui venaient
sur le stand. Et forcément,
quand on avait préparé la recette,
il fallait vérifier
qu'elle était bonne avant de vendre.
-Vous faisiez les cocktails ?
-Au début, oui.
C'est pour ça que je vous disais
que j'ai d'abord
eu un engagement militant.
J'ai distribué des tracts,
participé au stand
de la Fête de l'Huma.
-Ca donne une image
différente de vous,
peut-être plus fêtard
que vous en donnez l'impression ?
-Oh, "fêtard", oui...
Enfin, en tout cas,
j'aime bien,
comme plein de gens,
passer des bons moments
et pas uniquement
faire de la politique
qui peut parfois avoir
un côté froid, mais maintenant,
je dois être plus sérieux du fait...
-Fini, les mojitos !
-Ca n'empêche pas
de garder parfois des moments
où on peut se détendre et s'amuser,
mais avec un grand sens
des responsabilités.
Ce sera le mot de la fin. Merci,
Manuel Bompard, d'être venu.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...